all day they waited in hanforth
this corner of cheshire east had had
notice
that their parish council soap opera was
to be continued
it was of course their last meeting back
in december
when it all kicked off you have no
authority here jackie weaver
no authority at all she's just kicked
her mouth
no she's coming don't don't she kicks
him out don't
this is a meeting called by two
councillors
illegally they now elect a chairman
no the cop between the vice chairs here
i take charge
read the standing orders read them and
understand
the cool head that night was jackie
weaver they're not as a counselor but an
advisor
she wasn't due to log back on for the
sequel and just wants
peace to break out be kind to each other
it's not rocket science but my hope for
them is that actually we get to see
hanforth at its best
because it does have a best you know
talking about local issues for local
people
and so at 7 pm they logged on
it was open to the public so the public
joined in
but it didn't go well could i ask you
not to interrupt the councillors
i was just the chairman brian struggled
to maintain order please not interrupt
counsellors
maybe it's the effect of lockdown but
this council has actually prompted lots
of young people to find out more
about how very local politics works
i think initially when i first saw it i
was a little worried um
about the the impact it would have that
it would
you know push young people away because
the adversarial nature of the meeting
but what's been really inspiring to see
is how jackie um
has reframed the conversation and
narrative what we've seen is an increase
in young people who have access to video
through social media
now looking at councils as a potential
route to engage with democracy
back in the meeting it just carried on i
was trying
to be helpful george shut up
agreed yeah shut up george can i just
say
please let's respect each other then the
council has voted to mute the disruptive
members of the public
so their bickering could continue
uninterrupted
no we need to know you want to know that
you are aware that these minutes cannot
be deferred without a vulture
i'm not aware of that at all all right
can i ask that you speak to the proper
officer
to the clerk and ask his opinion no
you may not
tom parmenter sky news cheshire